Belle starr has come down through time
is one of the great Amzie heroines of the
old west. She is the bandit
Queen, the female Robin Hood,
who was quick with our fists and even
quicker with a Colt 45 the reality though
was quite different.
Develop history was a battler
who made some bad choices in men.
Ended up twice widowed with two children
and made the most of the cards she was
dealt only to me, it's the most
violence events in today's biographics.
We go beyond the legends to
reveal the Real Belle Starr
myra mayor bell Shelly.
The future bell star was born on
February the fifth 1848 in Jasper county,
southwest Missouri.
With that fact,
establish drilling down on the rest
of her life becomes far less. Certain.
Much of what is accepted is the
stuff of dime novel fiction.
Sorting out the fact from
the fiction here, it's been
a bit of a major challenge.
Now we do know that her father,
John Shirley was onto his third
wife when Myra came along.
That third wife was named Eliza Pennington
Hatfields and she was a member of the
Hatfield family. Who famously feuded
with the Mccoy's or the couple.
I had three other children, all of them
boys with Myra being the second oldest,
John Shirley.
He was a wheat corn and hog farmer.
When Myra was six years of age,
he sold the farm for a tidy profit
and relocated the family to Carthage,
Missouri.
He invested in real estate managing to
take possession of an entire city block
that housed a livery stable
blacksmith shop, a tavern,
and to hotel John Shelly.
He was a slave owner who is ardently pro
slavery in the explosive years before
the civil war.
Tensions.
They were high between pro and anti
slavery forces in Missouri when his oldest
son budge joins an infamous gang of
confederate sympathizers known as Quantros
Raiders John. He was extremely
proud. Meanwhile, Myra,
who insisted that she be
called bell whizzes growing
into a fine young lady. Uh,
parents were among the most prominence
in Carthage and she was able to enjoy
your life of semi privilege.
She attended the Carthage Female Academy
doing well in her studies where she
studied languages,
mathematics, and grammar.
She was also a talented piano player who
would entertain guests in the lobby of
the family owned hotel when he was
home from his rating expeditions bells,
older brother Bud taught her how to shoot.
She became an excellent shot developing
a reputation as a markswoman that would
later fuel her reputation
as the bandit queen.
So bell was 13 when the Civil Water
Apttus Carthage founds itself as a central
point of hostilities with no fewer
than 13 battles being waged in the
surrounding area during the four years
of the conflict with the war right on
their doorstep. Every person in
Carthage was forced to choose sides.
Pro and anti confederacy factions develops
with tensions escalating every single
day.
It has been reported that a teenage bell
acted as a spoiler for the confederacy
and even that she joined controls Raiders.
Both suggestions are unlikely.
However,
any news that she may have gotten about
a union treat movements she would no
doubt have passed onto.
But in June,
1864 bud was shot and killed by union
soldiers in [inaudible], Missouri.
When they surrounded the house that he
was in desperate to prevent any further
tragedy, the family packed
up and then move to Texas.
It turns out they got out of Carthage
just the right time. Three months later,
it was burned to the grounds
by confederate rebels
determined to drawing of
union soldiers out of the town bell jury
of one of the families wagons as they
wound their way down from
Missouri to a small town,
10 miles southeast of
Dallas called [inaudible].
Things doesn't go nearly as well for the
Shelley's in Texas as they had gone in
Missouri.
John had hoped to reinvest in a hotel,
but those plans didn't work out since
he was forced to return to farming.
Conflict arose with the locals who accused
John of taking more than his share of
water from the communal well,
bell was enrolled at the local one room,
school house, her attendance.
However, it was pretty erratic.
This was probably just cause she was
bored of the material having already
covered this when she was in college.
While that can cough edge bell had come
across a boy by the name of John Reed
Reed's who was two years older than bell,
joined quadrilles Raiders when he was
17 he was told and stocky and visibility
with his fists and a gun had and have
the respect of the other members of the
gang that admired him from afar,
but that family moved away before
a relationship could develop.
Bell was ecstatic to learn that
sometime around 1865 the reads that also
relocated to Texas, they quickly became
a couple ends on the 1st of November,
1866 they were married. Belle
was 18 at the time, Jim and bell,
they moved in with the Shirley family
where Jim helped out on the family farm.
Jim didn't take to farm work and see,
tried to sound as a salesman who worked
for a saddle maker in Dallas selling
saddles and bridles for a time
by the ends of 1867 however,
Jim's family had moved back to
Missouri and bell decided to join them.
Threads set themselves up
on a farm in Bates County.
Jim worked the lands with his brothers.
Then in September of 1868 belot gave
birth to a daughter Rosie leap from the
starch bell took to calling the baby
her little Pelle. Soon after this,
everyone was calling the maybe pile.
The first opportunity that John and Eliza
Shirley had to see their granddaughter
was when they'll rezone to Texas to attend
the funeral of a younger brother Ed.
The events surrounding
the murderer cloudy,
but it appears that he was involved in
horse theft following the funeral and
reunion with a parent's belt,
returns to the read farm in Missouri.
Her relationship with Jim,
it was strained as he spent less and
less time on the farm and more and more
time at the horse racing track.
It was one of the races that Jim ran into,
a man named Tom Star.
The star was a half Cherokee outlaw
who made a living by selling whiskey in
Indian territory. A practice which
happened to be a federal crime stall,
ran the enterprise with his sons and
they were soon joined by Jim read Jim's
foray into the outnet welds.
It escalated dramatically when
his brother Scott was murdered.
Jim vowed revenge and hunted down the
killer dispatching both and his brother
Bell, no founder stuff with a husband
who was being hunted by not just the law,
but also the friends of
the man who had killed.
We don't know what he did
that to support the family,
but suspicions are strong that it was
through such nefarious means a stagecoach
robbery and gambling.
On February the 22nd 1871 bell
gave birth to a second child,
a boy who they named James Edwin
nicknamed Eddie only a month laser.
Jim was accused of accounts of it,
money scam,
and was forced to gains
or relocate his family.
When the La authorities
began looking into his case,
they discovered that he
was also wanted for murder.
Jim Skips down and made us
wear on horseback to Texas
bell and the two children.
They followed him by stage coach in March,
1871 bell turns up at the family farm
in Texas with to your kids and to wanted
husbands.
Belle's father helped them set up on a
small fan near coon creek and boss county,
but Jim Reed had already
proven that he was no farmer.
Soon the farm was attracting a
regular assignment of vagabonds.
He would sit around with Jim and
plan out their various crimes.
Jim became involved in livestock russling
when he learns that a local man by the
name of Dick Crave,
he had $4,000 in cash stashed at his
home and his brother soul couldn't resist
the temptation.
However,
the robbery was botched and they ended
up murdering craving. A few months later,
the brothers were accused
of murdering another man.
This man whose last name was wheeler,
had apparently reported to the authorities
what he knew about the read mobs,
illegal activities he was
found with his tongue cut out.
This latest outrage resulted in both Jim
and soul having a $500 reward placed on
their capture that are alive and is of
course it was time to move. Once again,
leaving the children with bells.
Parents,
the couple of heads headed into Choctaw
Indian territory where the authorities
would be unable to follow them.
Jim was unable to stay out of trouble.
Like on November the 19th 1873
along with two accomplices,
he wrote to the farm of a wealthy retired
judge who live near the south Canadian
river,
the judge and his wife.
They were hung from a tree and forced to
divulge the location of the cash in the
house,
the bandits,
they got away with a huge
sum of $30,000 by now.
The strain on the marriage,
it was simply too much.
Mel was fed up with the life of crime
that her husband had forced her into.
She packed up and she took the children
back to the family farm in [inaudible].
Reid's headed for San Antonio where
he took up with a woman named Rosa us.
He continued his outlaw ways,
but fate caught up with him.
When the former associate shot him
in the back on August the sixth 1874
bell was now a widow and she had
two young children to take care of.
She stayed on the family
farm with our parents.
In 1876 John Shirley died this Forster
laser to sell the farm and relocate to
Dallas Bowel and the children.
They went with her.
Allegedly Bell was briefly married
for three weeks to Charles,
a younger uncle of coal younger in 1878
but this is not substantiated by any
evidence.
It's just a robot.
On during the fifth 1880 Bell Married Sam
Starve the son of her husband's former
associate Tom Star pins.
They settled in the Indian territory
there she learns ways of organizing,
panning,
and fencing for the rustlers horse thieves
and bootleggers as well as harboring
them from the law. Uh,
23 the half Cherokee,
Sam was nine years younger
than his new bride.
They moved into Cherokee nation
territory and settled into a homestead,
some 760 miles southwest of Fort Smith.
They cleared three acres of land and
planted corn that were plenty of fish in
the nearby river and gain results.
Also Pencil.
It seems like the ideal existence,
and it could have been if bells past
hadn't gotten in the way for associates of
Jim Reed, they began to learn the battle
had a hideouts in Indian territory,
which was safe from the reach of the law.
So many of these analogs
started showing up.
The bell was forced to convert and nearby
cave into a sort of robbers roost with
three log cabins in the interacted.
I've been zone now.
Bell had managed to keep herself from any
actual involvement in illegal activity.
This changed in 1882 when
she and Sam Austin neighbor,
if they could put some horses in
his pen a prior to selling them.
The neighbor agreed,
but it's on inspection pointed out that
at least two of the horses belonged to
other local farmers.
Salmon Bell ignored the claims and
went ahead and sold the horses when the
original owners of the start and horses
found out, so they press challenges.
Some of Bell,
they were handwritten and indictment to
appear before the court on the charge of
larceny. Sam's father Tom, he put up
bail for the couple, both bell and Sam.
They were found guilty. Sam was given a
years prison time in Detroit, Michigan.
Well, Bella was sentenced to
two concurrent, six months,
spells at the same facility with their
mother and stepfather in jail that
children were farmed out to
family and friends, Salmon Bell.
They were model prisoners
turning themselves in early
release, often nine months.
They sent a little back,
ends a life on the farm and things.
They were pretty quiet for a few months.
Then in December of 1884 a former
associate of Jim Reed by the name of Jim
Middleton, turns up looking for
a place of refuge from the law.
Middleton was wanted for murder,
runs the law.
They were pretty hot on his trail middles
and hung around the area for several
months.
Then one day,
Bellin Sam's ranch was rated by law
enforcement offices from Lamar County.
The offices had received permission from
the Cherokee nation lead is to conduct
the rate. Middleton was not
hat the residents at the time,
but the raid scad him enough to
make him want to make a run for it.
But with the law so close on his trail,
he couldn't figure out a way to get
out of the area without being detected.
Bell came to his rescue though,
suggesting that she drive a wagon with
the children in tow to visit relatives in
Arkadin soul Middleton, which hide
in the wagon God make his getaway.
When they were clear of
prying eyes the plan,
it was working well and then
off to sometime Middleton
was ready to light out on
his own. However, 17 year old pal
refused to let him take a horse.
This led to 14 year old Eddie heading
off to the nearest farm and an attempt to
do by a horse. He came back
with a broken down offline map.
It was hardly the ideal
getaway transport about is.
It was all the Middleton Hagins when
he sat out on his own with bells.
Colt 45 is only protection five days days.
Uh,
the horse was found in some scrub on
a riverbank not far from Fort Smith.
Then on May the 11th,
1885 Middleton's body was found a
couple of hundred yards downstream.
The authorities soon traced the gun
that was in his holster back to bell.
They also discovered that the horse
they legitimately purchased by Eddie had
previously been stolen.
The end result was that bell was
once again up on charges of larceny.
This time around Bella was found not
guilty. However, she returned time.
I need to discover that a husband Sam
had been wounded in a shootout with the
Indian police sound that now become
ensconced in his own life of crime.
Fearful of the rough justice that Indian
police were likely to dish out to.
Bell convinced him to hand himself
in to the federal authorities.
Sam was indicted for trial in February
of 1887 and then released on bail on
December the 17th.
Sam Bell and the children attended a
party at a neighbor's house. Everything.
It was laughter and Merriman's until Frank
West, the local law office, a town job.
He and Sam got into an argument and that
soon devolved into a gun battle in a
minutes.
Both of the men with debt,
Belle Starr was now widowed
for the second time.
Sam's death made possession of the ranch
on Cherokee land. A bit of a problem.
They had not bought the land.
It was in their possession because of
Sam's Indian blood. Now that he was dead.
How I've I bells right of possession.
It was disputed with pressure mounts
are going to have to get out of Cherokee
territory.
She decided there was another solution.
She married sounds brother
Bill, July ATS, Jim's star,
and we've actually was once again
married to a Cherokee and so she had
possession rights to the land.
Now 39 bell was 15 years
older than her third husband.
The marriage of convenience.
It was not pleasing to Pearl age 19 or
Eddie age 17 both of them constantly
argued with Jim,
which was a source of ongoing frustration
for bell around this time pole fell in
love with a young man who in the course
of time approached bell to Oscar consent
to marry her daughter Bell flatly refused.
Giving the reason that she had long told
pell that she could only marry a man
who had at least $25,000 worth of
property she needs or trying to trick the
young men by sending them a letter
with poles forged signature on it,
stating that she had married someone else.
The young couple of though,
they soon figured out the reason,
continued to see each other behind bells.
Back before long pellet became
pregnant bell, she was not happy.
You're giving her daughter two options,
have an abortion or never bring the
child into her presence. Pell Chase,
the latter option giving birth
to a girl called philosophy.
On April the 22nd 1887 she took the
babies and live with her paternal
grandparents. In 1987 Jim was arrested
for horse theft. By this time,
however,
bell was making an effort to go straight.
She had stopped allowing fugitives
to use a places, a hideouts.
When it came time for Jim's trial,
she refused to assist in his defense.
Meanwhile, young Edie stone
was having his own problems.
He was shots while trying to steal a
horse belt. Fears that he would die.
She sent a message to Paul telling her
that she had better come back to see how
brother for the last time she added,
however,
she was not to bring the baby pillow
returned to see Eddie who recovered from
his injury.
Bell put pressure on a daughter to give
up philosophy for adoption during the
visit. Po outrightly refused,
but val was a stubborn woman.
She maneuvered things behind the scenes
and philosophy was taken from and placed
into an orphanage in November of 1888
I think it was now up on horse theft
charges of his own again,
belt refuse to participate in the Defence
Eddie's trial that was scheduled for
March of 1889 he returned to the family
homestead and reportedly threatened to
kill his mother.
He then took off never to see belt again.
Bells problems escalated when a couple
of the Watsons turned up at the farm
looking for sharecropping work. Bell
decided to take them up on their offer.
Keens and some extra money. Bell
became quite friendly with Mrs. Watson.
On one occasion.
The woman revealed that in a husband's
was as actually wanted for murder.
This scores warning bells in bell's minds
if the Cherokee tribal council found
out that she was again
harboring fugitives,
they would surely kick her off the land.
Bell offered to give the Watsons there
sharecropping feedback and we'll just to
get them to leave, but
I'd go Watson. He refused.
It was only when bell revealed that
she knew that Watson was a wanted man,
that he left taking up with his
wife in a nearby tenant. Kevin,
on July the second 1889
bell as a young husband Jim,
they left on horseback to meet Jim's
trial appointments at Fort Smith.
Bells intention was to
accompany them halfway,
pay a debt to the store on King's
creek and then return home.
They stayed the night with friends
and 20 miles from Fort Smith.
The next morning bell town for home while
Jim carried onto the fort bell stopped
off at King's creek.
We actually had lunch at the local store.
Further along the trail, she stops at
the home of a man named Jackson. Wrote.
This was a popular meeting place for
locals. She hoped to see our son Eddie,
who had been staying there,
but he left before she arrived
though was Edgar Watson,
the sharecropper who forced off
her land as his doorbell arrive.
He promptly left after a short time
eating and conversing with friends.
Bell got back on her horse and continued
towards time. However, she never made it.
She was blasted from
ours by a shotgun blast.
The killer then approach the dying figure
on the grounds and blustered again,
bells panic, toss it. Gallup's for home.
That concern to pal set
out to find her mother.
At the time she got to the murder site,
a young boy had already found the
body bell mistaken to a farmhouse,
barely alive.
Pell was just in time to be alongside
the moment that her mother took her last
breath.
The question of who killed Belle Starr
has intrigued historians for well over a
century.
Both of our children have been suspects.
Eddie has threatened his
mother at least one selfish.
She had disciplines in with a bullwhip
that the most likely candidates is they'd
go Watson. Watson was actually put
on trial for the murder. However,
the evidence was deemed as
circumstantial and he was acquitted.
He eventually returned to Florida where
he was killed in a shootout with a posse.
No other efforts were ever made to
track down the killer of Bell Star.
There were several other
potential suspects besides Watson,
including July himself,
and I don't really,
July had been caught with
the young Cherokee girl.
End Bell had been making his life hell
just a few weeks after bell's death.
July was mortally wounded by a deputy.
It was on his trail,
so the facts of bell's does
life not exactly as exciting
or as outlandish as the
fictionalized version that began
with a dime novel, Belle Starr,
the bandit queen or the female Jesse
James in 1889 in summarizing how life or a
Fort Smith Elevator report there about
a year before her death, Bell said,
I regard myself as a woman
who has seen much of life.
The reality was that she was
not the female Jesse James.
She wasn't even a bandit queen.
What she was was a twice widowed woman
with two children who did what she could
to survive.
Only today to be shot down in cold blood.
This is a story of hardship and
tragedy in the real old west,
her grave site,
isn't it?
If our naked Oklahoma or horse
was engraved on our tombstone,
along with these words shed not
for her, the bitter tier, no,
give the heart to then regress.
Tis, but the casket that lies here,
the gem that filled it sparkles yet,
so I already have you found in that video.
Interesting. If you did, give us a thumbs
up below and don't forget to subscribe.
If you're looking for something
else to watch right now,
they check out a video from the
archives and link to on the screen.
Or if you look into something
completely different to watch,
why not check on another channel? I do.
Cool. Top tens. Find a link to that below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.